i sat down with a former fbi agent last
week or two weeks ago was it two weeks
ago jim clem is it jim clemente jim
clemente okay
and uh uh 20 plus years fbi his brother
was an fbi agent fully qualified fbi and
true believer fbi like there's a reason
why he became an fbi agent there was a
motive behind what happened with his
personal life when he was younger we
won't get into that right now so i said
tell me about nurture versus nature you
know like a guy that ends up becoming a
killer and takes someone's life is it
nurtures the nature i love the way he
used it i think it kind of validates
your point here's what he said he said
genetics loads the gun
yes okay he said personality and
psychology aims the gun
and then he says experiences of your
life makes you pull the trigger
so are you saying some people are born
evil and they just can't help but divide
what about the guy who just that
drove his suv into a crowd
that's insane and there's there's all
kinds of like killers and murderers what
about stalin who
and mao who oversaw and hitler oversaw
the killing of millions of their own
people
how how how is how is that
how is that
trained it's got to be in you
okay and i i believe what what the your
fbi man said it's true i actually once
met uh a couple of triplets that were
separated at birth
and were brought up in three different
uh uh
families
three different settings and they were
incredibly alike you're probably
familiar with that of course they did
yeah of course they did a documentary on
them yes and i actually i actually
tutored each one of them
so i knew him well get out of here
yes i was in college for them what a
great story yeah yeah so your point is
your point is
hitler was born evil it's not the fact
that they made fun of him and then
didn't let him go into that one school
or institution that offended him that
made him want to say for the rest of my
life i'm gonna get my vengeance
uh
yes that that's my my claim and yes and
there had to be other things that to
fall into place triggers
uh and uh
and enablement
right so you know you don't you don't
you cannot act on your evil nature just
just because you want to and you don't
have to be positioned in that way jack i
got two more questions before we wrap up
uh uh to finish this off one of them is
honey pot you know the whole red sparrow
story how much truth is there behind
that
a lot also that one is true
oh
yes
a lot yeah oh man yeah
the
uh the best of them was actually um east
germany you know but they had they had
the uh romeo's that they'd worked with
men yes oh sex and espionage
historically there's always been a great
marriage so to speak uh-huh
so if you like this sort of clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye